now in Android studio you can hit the
play button to run the app on your
device in the device chooser dialog you
should see your connected device to
prevent the dialogue from popping up in
future times check this box then hit OK
to continue
within a few moments you should see it
on your phone on the other hand as Rado
was mentioning you can use command-line
tools from the root folder of the
project use Gradle W to build your app
on Mac or Linux check the link in the
notes below if you're using Windows this
first command grants execution
permission to the Gradle wrapper script
and you only need to do it the first
time you're trying to build from the
command line then you can call Gradle W
assemble debug once the build is
successful it creates an APK file at the
app build apk directory you can use ADB
to install the app the - arc command
means that you can replace an existing
version of the app if you've already
done it before for more tips on ADB you
can see the instructor notes below then
you can use this atv command with the
activity manager tool in order to start
the main activity there you see it on
the device and now we see it running on
our phones
wha-hoo this bump we're on a roll
let's go find Dan so that we can build
up the sunshine UI